you know what man there's some really
creepy videos and crazy YouTube like
propaganda videos about Cova and and and
buy weapons and stuff mm-hmm I don't I'm
not I'm not into all that stuff but
we've got the next segment is this crazy
conspiracy theory so why don't we do
this why don't we jump to the the next
the conspiracy theories story check this
stuff out man
this one is sending the internet wild
coronavirus in Pittsburgh researcher
killed an apparent murder-suicide was
close to making very significant
findings related to kovat 19 Pitt said
perhaps he would have discovered
something that would have unmasked the
whole plan maybe he was like oh whoa
it's not that bad no maybe he was like
my word the protein sequences on this
prove it was manufactured by a you know
whatever yeah yeah and I assert insert
whatever you want conspiracy and then he
was taken out and then he was I don't
know I'm just being silly but he
actually was killed liked here's a dude
I don't know was researching and this
could actually be sad because maybe like
his finding was gonna be some treatment
or something yeah maybe
let's read the story from KDKA CBS
Pittsburgh they say a researcher killed
in an apparent murder-suicide was close
to making very significant findings
related to the corona virus his
department at the University of
Pittsburgh said two shootings that
happened over the weekend in Ross
Township appeared to be a murder-suicide
according the police on May 2nd police
said 37 year old dr. Bing Liu was found
dead in his home on Elm Court from
apparent gunshot wounds to the head to
his head neck and torso investigators
say they now believe his death is a
homicide Lew is a research assistant
professor at the University of
Pittsburgh School of Medicine his
department said on Monday being was on
the verge of making very significant
findings toward understanding the
cellular mechanisms that underlies
Tsarskoe vid to infection and the
cellular basis of the following
complications we will make an effort to
complete what he started in an effort to
pay homage homage to his scientific
excellence the department said on its
website his loss will be felt throughout
the entire scientific community
please keep his family friends and
colleagues in your thoughts thank you
here's we got to watch out for will the
people who pick up his research also
mysteriously died of course I was
thinking that exact thing no I'm careful
his stories probably like so much on
that side some woman that he you know
scorned or something or some jaded rival
of some sort you know it's never gonna
be as exciting as a movie I guess that
being said have you seen that clip of
the the show the debt was a call the
deadzone I think it's going viral I saw
something about it go and borrow but I
didn't want it's like it's an episode
called plague and in it there's
something that acts like a virus they
can't identify it and the guys like it's
this and then like they can't figure how
to treat it but then he has like a dream
vision where it's like chloroquine the
chloroquine chloroquine and then he's in
the room and they're like he opens the
book and goes this this is the virus and
the doctor goes there's no cure for that
and he goes chloroquine and then he
writes it on a whiteboard and like
underlines it and she goes that's an
anti-malarial drug and he goes it
inhibits the enzyme and then the next
scene is like him waking up in a
hospital bed he like collapses then he
wakes up in a hospital bed and the the
one guy he's like what happened he goes
we started everyone on chloroquine and
it stopped it dead in its tracks it's
like a weird it's like weird yeah how
old is this from mm something like 90s I
don't know Wow okay yeah yeah so it's an
old show hmm but you know anyway the
point is who knew I don't I don't I
don't know if we're actually in a movie
but I brought that up because well you
know actually we kind of are in you know
some kind of fictional something yeah
but there's another there's another
funny thing on add to this so I look I
can't tell you exactly what this is but
I do want to talk about some of the
conspiracy theories that are floating
around but we also have this story take
us out
oh yeah third third doctor falls from
hospital window after coronavirus
complaint gee I wonder what's happening
there hmm let me just complain all
should be in quotes it just keeps
happening it's it's a drafty window
someone should really close that window
yeah it would be like could you imagine
I kind of feel bad laughing though it's
not not really funny a paramedic who
complained about being forced to work
despite contracting Crona virus is in
critical condition after he fell from a
hospital window in western Russia this
weekend this is at least the third
incident in which a Russian healthcare
professional has plunged from a
spittle building under mysterious
circumstances but he survived it but the
fact that they're calling it mysterious
circumstances shows they know wait a
minute what's going on well how do you
fall out of a window of a hospital
because those things are you know
they're the low windows so you gotta
like open up no before this it's not
like the big huge open slide big window
at least I don't think it would be
really funny if like I'm just imagining
this it's like the window in a bathroom
uh-huh and the soap dispenser is right
next to the window and people keep
pressing it like the soap nuts up on the
ground and so the reason it keeps
happening is just some silly coincidence
where like he goes to grab the window
and slips and falls out and it keeps
happening here we are assuming it's
Vladimir Putin throwing people from the
building or something
yeah no it's actually more likely
they're being thrown from the building
if you were to ask me it definitely
sounds like it yeah I mean how do you
fall out of a hospital falls out three
three different people fell out of the
and it's probably I don't know if it's
the same window maybe yeah maybe
probably same window it's like taking a
helicopter ride yeah yes in Russia yeah
no complaint hospital that I used to
work at the windows did not open at all
so that people couldn't fall out that's
the whole point
see that makes sense to me I don't know
seems weird to me
well sketchy yeah they say she'll UPOV
and his colleague filmed a video on
April 22nd complaining the chief doctor
of the Nova Novaya husband village
hospital forced him to work despite the
fact he tested positive for kovat a
second video appeared three days later
in which Shula paav denied his initial
emotional claims his colleague Alexander
kostyan reportedly faces criminal
charges for spreading fake news about
the virus which carries a prison
sentence of up to five years under a
recently passed federal law this is so
weird you know man I'm sorry I'm just
gonna say it I don't trust anything
that's going on I have no idea what's
happening I have no idea how bad this is
they keep flip-flopping you know people
are getting thrown out of windows dudes
getting murdered he's denying his
initial emotional claims but then they
don't they don't say it under his breath
he said please don't throw me out the
window again I think I figured out
what's going on what we are in a movie
because we aren't the main characters
clearly not so we're just like off to
the side of the main story arc yeah I'm
like what is it what is this so so
here's here's the funny story they're
all connected like the main action hero
guy like you know he shows up to find
his friend dr. Liu murdered and ya know
and he chased after the criminal flag
gets on a plane to Russia and finds him
and there's like a doctor a doctor in
full gear and he sees him he's like I
got to run he's like you know he opens
the window and kills himself because he
doesn't want to get interrogated some
things like know you'll never stop us
kill one of us and two more will come in
its in his place my jaw jumps out he's
like no give me answers or he's like
holding on to him is like don't drop
some it's all related but we just can't
tell because we're just sitting do you
work for ya so there's some crazy
there's a bunch of crazy conspiracy and
propaganda videos that are popping up
all over the place naturally YouTube
will ban you face Facebook's been
banning people who talk about like
queuing on stuff so they're basically
just decided if you see anything that is
not approved truth I'm just gonna press
that button and get rid we've got a
bunch of weird things happening with
this virus we've got have you heard of
Co vid toes yeah as well people get
blisters and ulcers on their feet yeah
Basti is it real though that's what
they're saying in the news yeah yeah
sure it's a picture I could put I could
post a blister and say oh look this is
now happening and then spread throw it
out into the wind and see what happens
so so either we have this crazy virus
which causes like 50 different things
right from strokes to pneumonia to
sickle-cell to lesions on your feet and
all the deaths of all other diseases are
going down there's all the difference
they're not they're not going down I
thought that they remember though the
flu the flu deaths were significantly
lower from what I've seen
no okay and certainly there are a lot of
people who are claiming it's the case
that's not the case right and so one of
the things I know it's not the case but
that's what they were claiming for a
little the the charts of average deaths
are boom they spiked
yeah skyrocket right I saw that in the
CDs yeah and and I went over all data to
for like New York
the average deaths are dramatically
higher than normal so what's happening I
mean it does make sense that there is
some new virus that hit the human race
okay if there's a new virus that causes
pneumonia that causes your red blood
cells to deteriorate that causes lesions
and blisters on your feet that causes
the loss of taste and smell that causes
nerve damage that causes heart damage
that causes reproductive damage and that
and what's the last one Oh seizures and
strokes have all been reported what
reported but is it is it like for sure
as a did a doctor come out and be like
yes we dressed but these have all been
reported by mainstream established press
these things are happening trusts and
mainstream established press trust them
I'm saying this is what we're being told
yeah and so now I'm sitting here where
they were like don't buy masks they
don't do anything then they were like
make sure you get your masks now they're
like if you don't wear a mask we'll find
you yeah or or arrest you and beat you
up yeah yeah yeah walk up walk up you it
will punch you in the face
yeah slay me to the ground well that cop
got in trouble but what sure a slap on
the wrist
well he's suspended for now we'll see
yeah he's probably with pay probably
yeah yeah paid vacation mm-hmm we'll see
what happens to that guy probably
nothing what they do is they take
immediate action like we're suspending
him and then they wait a week until no
one cares anymore longer are you back
yeah exactly
go ahead and punch the next guy see
we'll just do it again but so there's a
bunch of propaganda videos arguing that
this is a bioweapon right okay I
actually disagree based on everything I
just said all the weird things happening
yeah I think if this was and we talked
about before too about walks then you
know we'll talk about it again if this
was a bio weapon I think it would be a
bit more focused
yeah I agree more specific assuming all
of these weird symptoms are real mm-hmm
then it sounds like what Fox News
reported that it was China just you know
screwing around in a lab being like oh
yeah let's just do this that in this and
this makes him a random and then it
breached yep
but I guess what the official story
that's going around right now is that
it's not man-made that it was you know
you've got a bunch of outlets trying to
conflate the two arguing that because
Trump and Mike Pompeo have said that
this they believe this came from a
okay then people in media trying to
conflate that to me it was man-made but
then and say that the what what Trump in
Pompeii actually said something
something the fact of I believe that
China was doing research on an existing
coronaviruses and there was a breach
yeah that makes more sense to me I don't
I don't know man I don't know anything
about anything it was an accident it got
out maybe okay but it's causing all
these weird things yeah so if it's if
these things are not true and it's not
causing all of these weird at weird at
symptoms then what are we supposed trust
about any of it I know exactly now
there's this whole thing to or there's a
new deadlier strain that they're finding
and it's like but I looked into it a
little bit and it's like there's no
information it's just a tag line so why
do they want us to stay in our houses so
bad I don't know people don't care
anymore they're julievan they are
they're just well you'd be cool what if
it was aliens if it was aliens what
kovat is actually no no no like aliens
are coming and so the governments are
all panicking like what do we do and
then like the people who BOTS like what
if like on one day at one time the
aliens fire like some kind of like EMP
radiation blast just vaporized everybody
outside everyone that's outside but yeah
you're inside your home you're you're
fine yeah you're safe
dude this is the stupidest thing about
what's happening is when you see these
people that are lying for the sake of
tribalism like that woman who said the
vaporized beach water could have the
virus in it yeah what are you talking
about or that that that writer for Jimmy
Kimmel or whatever her she was like my
dad's a doctor he said if you're young
you'll have a stroke shut up what you've
made this so unbelievable yeah by
screeching all this it was way more than
that too
it was like a law yes nuts like dude if
you came out and said there's a virus it
causes pneumonia I'd be like oh I don't
want to get that yeah
but then when you come out you're like
well it causes pneumonia it takes away
your tents a sense of taste and smell it
damages your heart your lungs your your
if you're a man it hurts your testicles
it also causes a stroke and seizure and
any nerve damage toes get blistery your
toes will bleed and lesion and I'm like
okay just just stop right there
what yeah wait what is this like you
saying things maybe it's real maybe it's
doing all these things I mean it's been
reported
the press am I supposed to come out and
be like this is a the most powerful
virus we've ever seen it can do all
these things
maybe maybe they don't even know it's
we're supposed to believe anymore at
this point I gotta be honest I am I
agree with you so maybe this guy in
Pittsburgh found something yeah maybe he
found the cure maybe he was like oh wait
actually this cures it and they're like
oh we can't cure this yet or we're not
we're not done consolidating our power
or he zoomed in with an electron
microscope on one of the viruses huh and
he kept zooming in and zooming in and
then very very very tiny writing will
suggest one of the virus said Gates
Foundation and then he took a big
cluster of the virus and he held his
phone near it and he got five G signal
and he was like oh it's the phone virus
yeah they're out there man but Saul so
the conspiracy theories from the media I
don't know what I'm supposed to believe
anymore we we went to Los Angeles
we got tested for the antibodies at
Rogen's and we were all negative and I'm
like I don't know because they flip-flop
so much in the press whether I should be
terrified of this or be over it but you
can tell when you look in New York and
LA and so the places people are over it
they are they're completely over they
don't care anymore and that's the places
where it's like the most populated -
yeah they're over it yeah it's only a
matter of time before we see what's
gonna happen out basically the numbers
were all wrong the amount of people who
have died is substantially lower than
they initially projected yep so far even
with the stay at home order they were
like yes we're gonna 200 this much death
and it's like way down here
yeah well it's at 200 now it's 72 or
whatever which is really bad it's it's a
lot of people we don't know for sure so
I'm wondering if it really is still this
bad and people in New Yorker to find
this order know better get sick and die
I guess so isn't that their
constitutional right yeah yeah you're
allowed to be dumb freedom of
association so is that is that how New
York ends everybody goes to the beach
and parties and they get sick I got to
tell you man I'll make a prediction
right now nothing's gonna happen you
know why it's nothing like no Boogaloo
or oh no I don't know about that I'm
saying I don't think New York's gonna
see a massive spike due to people going
out yeah I agree
South Dakota I'm with it because
whatever whatever it Dakota right
nothing happened and it was supposed to
be the hot spot nothing and that's
because the media lies it's cuz the meat
you know what it is the reason why that
woman bests or whatever her name was
went on Twitter and said you'll have a
stroke you'll drop dead your lungs will
stop working its tribalism it's like
that woman saying I wouldn't go to the
beach if you paid me a million dollars
because the virus is in the air sort of
saying before they're just a hairy
little kid there's a little look-see
what I did no you see what I told all
these people right look how awesome I am
hearing that it's Karen being like you
need to listen to me I'm telling you
you'll die you'll regret it it's like
okay I get it shut up dude I'm not
listening anymore so what happens next
I honestly have no idea yeah but the
conspiracy theories certainly are fun
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you